california california california
the middle class famous tour is coming
to the left coast yeah guys april we're
going to be in san francisco april 4th
we're going to be in los angeles april 6
we're going to be in la jolla get your
tickets now it's a little bit of stand
up it's a little bit of ayg it's a whole
lot of fun do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it sure is it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they grow up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash
i'm your host holy coming at you a
little bit under the weather coming at
you from the icu this week god damn big
man down here at aunt tooty's basement
uncle hank got a bad claims casino the
other night i think
i got something working through me
coming out like a bad cat
doing number one out of the two been
there oh it smells like grim death down
there i'm your host h foley we're down
here in aunt toddy's basement she's
upstairs i think she ran to the grocery
store my co-host is coming at you from
across the table at me he is the ceo of
are you garbage he was voted mr steal
your girl summer of 2002.
give it up for kevin james ryan i think
i might have been doing all right in
2000
2006 was probably my year but uh happy
to be here thanks for tuning in we've
seen photographic evidence of the
country it might have been seven you
would never slim down
i'm telling you why why why why i'm
telling you there was one summer when i
was [ __ ] binge drinking and living
off three dollar chicken cheese takes
from 17th and diamond and i poppy i was
tight as a drum it wasn't healthy i
probably had a couple of days left
breath was horrible but still
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true the roof [ __ ] cooking babe
we're closing in on like 45 000
something around there and a 40 thousand
428 but that's high that's great i'm
you're pumping the numbers pumping
dupsky
these poses you guys you guys subscribe
and then find 10 more subscribers um
and now they're subscribing to you yes
exactly pyramid youtube uh then
obviously patreon.com the greatest
website of all time honestly
it is that is i say that as a joke but
in my life
your life
my wife's life
no other website has impacted us this
much none aol maybe when i was doing it
uh age sex location show that
xnxx.com
not too shabby that that revolutionized
the game in about 2011.
talking about rubber meeting the road
and then guys live shows uh
california tickets are moving for sure
los angeles is sold out by the time this
is there tickets are already moving and
[ __ ] sf tickets are really moving in
la jolla get them now then obviously
pittsburgh buffalo detroit maybe adding
something on the tail end of that just
saying
uh phoenix
uh salt lake city get the [ __ ] tiki
tiki tikis look at that l.a selling out
baby
la la land a seven seater but we're
doing all right
it's just a suburban but still it's a
black box and encino gang having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man making us
all look good one of my best pals very
forgiving young man
tune into the patreon
give it up for toby
mr
toby mcmullen sir
oh mr toby mcmullen's my dad please call
me ticket
call me huge loser what's with the right
guard mini i'm the thing i forgot to put
deodorant on before i left the apartment
i keep a stash in the studio so i don't
get sort of pitted up in here damn it's
very teenager of you yeah i got quite a
funk little axe body yeah do you kick
hard oh yeah even fresh out of the
shower
like after if you if you forget to put
on deodorant what's the shelf life on on
a mcmullen five six seconds really oh i
go bad like an old peach
[Laughter]
and all peach avocado mcmullen over here
only rape for three days a year what's
with those those avocados i can't get a
real ghost i got a dude i got one that's
funny they're like shape shifters oh man
i got one that [ __ ] who had died on
the vine in the back of my fridge i saw
it two days ago left that for the missus
and it was mine but she gets them and
use them i get them and i'm like i have
one half of breakfast or something like
ah this later tonight you gotta use the
whole thing you'll use a whole avocado
what do you do a half of an eye a half
yeah you're crazy this is the difference
between 225 and 400 avocado's good fat
yeah lay off it though you know what'll
really shrink up beyond gross as [ __ ]
it's a banana this just turns into a
mummy oh i don't i'm not a banana guy i
gotta say my wife doesn't believe me
they're real decepticons those bananas
cause sometimes the outside could look
really really nice and you open that
thing up and it's goddamn
this is gross this might this will this
is this will blow your hair back a
little bit this has been verified by my
my wife didn't believe me verified by my
mother
okay i've never had a banana
up yeah i swear to god there's no way
that's true
i'm telling you what about when you were
a little fat kid your little nanners i
had my [ __ ] slim fast and now she
goes i knew when you were a baby she's
like maybe you weren't eating chicken
porn as little as a little baby no but
me she's like maybe like mashed at a
time but net like it just
i've never i've never bitten into a
banana really uh-uh
man yeah it's strange i'm an odd guy
when it comes to the foods oh there's a
lot that i don't mess with i just
started eating red meat
out of college never saw the matrix
never saw the matrix weird
if there's any podcast hiring looking
for production staff i am now available
yeah me too
hey i'm willing to learn
well let's start from the bottom sir
you're in the mail room if you know what
dude
morning mr kelly
trying to go over mushy mike's head
the male rumor white kw that's a good
one t-bone
hey good job boss love you buddy
man i am hurting for a squirting over
here that means you want to be [ __ ]
right oh yeah
i stick to my statement but still not
now i'm all messy back there
yeah i couldn't imagine i couldn't
imagine on a good day it's good it's not
bad
i have some special brushes
that i have in the shower tail help
yourself to the main entails long
reachers they get in there
yeah i just got a new exfoliating brush
that looks like a horse brush that you
you you rub it on dry dry rub rush my
wife uses it right before you get in the
shower yes sephora yeah not a bad spot i
know i never liked that kind of stuff on
the testicles yeah
that's what you're paying for having
pain or pleasure maybe you choose
could you do that
dominatrix could you be a dominant do
you like anything like that dominated
yeah you like anything
safe word banana
i don't think so man i'm a pretty kind
you know i'm a pretty meat and potatoes
kind of guy candle wax
i don't i i don't think i've ever done
it nipple play
yours
yeah i like i've i've said i'm kind of
uh you know your nipples probably look
like a pill box in world war ii no
they're [ __ ] barbed wire
stevie wonders
uh
two guys from the ss on the 88 titties
wit uh
[Laughter]
i'm not i'm not weird i'm i'm you know
i'm a [ __ ] turkey and cheese kind of
guy you know uh
but i'm not very sensitive kind of
anywhere what about you timo could you
[ __ ] it up
no that's not my scene ball gag
on me yeah no leather no i could see you
drinking milk in an orgy though
it's just way too comfortable
just hanging out in dirty sweatpants
not even thinking about getting naked
just hanging yeah
i'm a watcher
i don't even think you're watching now
you're just you know [ __ ] i like to
be what do you think i'm gonna talk
watching the games yeah i don't know you
know talking shop
i took a pint of floating out of the
water
you have to put two of two months first
last security what are you doing i was
pretty i was pretty well known for doing
stupid [ __ ] like that when i was uh
underserved you're still pretty well
known for doing stupid [ __ ] i might not
well back in the day when i was under
certain influences
yeah all right uh
where are you in this
sunny day colt what are you doing did
rasputin have your ear i couldn't think
of the cult
i got real big in a hail bop
you're not welcome here
gandalf
i see you lord of the rings fans out
there
um
nose beers
we'll say i know
some underage audience i don't want to
condone any anyway i'd be in after-hours
places with certain people
from certain um
walks of life walks of life
in certain neighborhoods where you don't
really ask a lot of questions sure and
i'd be in there yeah like ah how many
taps you guys have right who owns this
yeah really really ruining the vibe yeah
really ruining the vibe yeah it's kind
of my special do ask too many questions
especially for that kind of i've never
been to one of those settings but i
assume those settings
aren't you know now a lot of like now
you know how long you've been working
here that kind of thing i remember one
time we had had something where we had
to wear a suit and we ended up at this
after hours place and we walked in in
suits and dude i swear to god like four
a bunch of ball bears
[Music]
[Laughter]
like four or five guys ran out they
thought we were cops we just learned
then hey what's going on in here oh the
flashlight's in bad just kind of i stink
i know
um i had a little sticky i don't know
it's probably the most garbage thing
i've done in quite a while
um you know i have this new pup right
the dog the dog
shout out to hans head of security hansi
ponzi but she is not reported for duty
yet he is not when is his training gonna
be over uh what do you mean what's boot
camp over he's uh
he's currently with uh some ex-massage
agents really really learning the ropes
and yeah
you know fake noses and all that kind of
stuff yeah everything yeah
securing the hard drive type stuff
he's more of an analyst
um
but it was the middle of the night sleep
he's a little bit of a wonky sleeper so
we put him in this pen we got a pen for
him
and i woke up in the middle of the night
yeah and had it i had to tinky
take a take a leak but i didn't want to
wake him up
how are you not waking up a puppy what
do you mean there's no way you can
tiptoe around there that's what i'm
saying i didn't want to wake him up i
understand so i may have
i may have relieved myself what
in a flower pot in the in the bathroom
in the shower i didn't make it to the
shower
because you don't want to wake him up i
don't want to wake him up i was drinking
watching a lot of colombo i got this i
can solve it off top what do you got
yeah one more thing one more thing you
were pissed into a gatorade bottle on
your couch you were very close it wasn't
gatorade
coke zero drop 50.
wow wide mouth
got it a lot of room there yeah
cause trying to pee into like a regular
bottle like this you don't stand up
you're you don't stand a chance
and then there's that game you gotta be
wahlberg there's that gauge of how quick
it's filling up and you can tell by how
warm your hand's getting yikes i've lost
that in a driver's seat a couple of
times
dropped a bottle uh no well i was peeing
this was one time i was leaving the
raven lounge i stopped at uh wawa that
used to be over there on philmont ave
you know it well and bustleton philmont
i have in bustleton up there in uh
northeast philadelphia no i don't they
don't have a um
bathroom this is before superwall watch
they do
but they don't want you using it yeah
they don't have a public bathroom so i
you're at a pee real bad
uh
real bad
and like there's like nowhere you can
pee on the side like i would have got
jammed up i would have got like a public
you know urination type deal and uh so i
peed in a you know some sort of soda
bottle or a wawa iced tea bottle and
that didn't i mean
man all over the seats of the montego
and then i had to drive home and it was
were you doing it while you were driving
no i did it in the parking lot okay yeah
did you throw the bottle out no i saved
it and had it for breakfast with a
bottle
uh
yeah but it was not a not not one of my
best where was the trap 50 bottle i had
taken it to sleep with me because i was
sleeping on the couch because he needs
he needed someone in the room not
anymore now he's a big dog was it empty
uh yeah it might have been you know a
couple of mouse swings in there why'd
you take it with you to bed because i
had something to swing on i think i was
you know a couple of swigs what kind of
what was the consistency of the pee some
pulp mostly
[Laughter]
no as you know i'm a no pulp man i
strained it was it was it p pineapple p
cranberry what are we talking about uh
yeah so it was just straight drop 50
peed in there and it was like as i was
doing i'm like well this has to make the
podcast it was one of like i think
that's two garbage moves right there if
i'm if i must interject i'm listening
bringing orange juice with you to bed
it's all we
had what dude warm orange juice
come on it wasn't warm
it wasn't but it wasn't cold i finished
it while i was sitting on the couch okay
and then i laid down and then it was
like you know there was like that much
in the i was done with it maybe if i
would have waken up at three in the
morning i would have wet my whistle a
little bit sure you know what i mean
those days at that point you just need
to you just need moisture it doesn't
matter i can drink the pee at that warm
ginger ale in the middle of the night
nothing wrong with it there's nothing
better than in the middle of the night
i don't do it anymore but i used to back
in the day i was like hot the [ __ ]
air conditioner in my mom's house sucked
so in like august it would be 5 000
degrees upstairs
and he's come stumbling down you were in
like high school or whatever just like
[ __ ] you know in a haze sweaty your
[ __ ] ring of your neck's all wet and
drawn out and just getting like a cool
jesus christ a cold bottle of [ __ ] a
cold
two-liter a coke or something nightmare
really wet the [ __ ] whisky yeah that
was all right i have severe stomach
cramps right now okay
then we want to place an over-under bet
on if he has to remove himself to go to
the bathroom and if so what minute will
that be at uh i'm gonna put it at 42 and
a half minutes okay what are we at now
just so i have a benchmark we just hit
20. okay on the recording not
necessarily the episode all right so
we're to say we're about 17 ish i'm
gonna say you don't make it past 47
minutes well i got news for you i [ __ ]
my pants
i'm like the hulk i already [ __ ] my page
um i don't think it's coming
from that direction you think it's
coming out you're tossing your cookies
as they say yeah oh dude if you puke in
here we're gonna have to move and i'm
gonna fight with the landlord i throw up
right here right now you're upset with
me
i asked i'm not upset with you i'm upset
at this situation i'm literally doing
this
and leaving for two weeks so they can
steam clean this [ __ ] place
biohazard get those guys little army get
those guys from monsters inc in here
a little army guy i asked toby in the
car
i'm sorry i was steamrolling i apologize
um
i asked toby in the car
i throw up in here are you throwing up
immediately no no really i i'm i think
you're underestimating how quick i'm out
of here this is all this is a dead zone
to me this is old this might as well be
chernobyl um i'm never using the
computer again no really
it's a good way to get a new laptop
i don't only puked
[Laughter]
yeah it was pretty fun jesus time you
just go scott
seconds oh my god so i don't know i
don't mean i don't know if he's still
alive at this point that's not good man
yeah he could just you know pull the
[ __ ] cord this guy's gonna trick that
esophagus what the [ __ ] yeah pretty wild
uh foley hit me with one that i haven't
heard in a long time uh because he was
the flat ginger ale to settle the
stomach was that did your mom do that
growing up ginge for sure ginger elf we
didn't have ginger ales clear liquid so
we would do sprite as well
[Laughter]
dude soda as remedy is so trash dude
sprite in the 90s it might as well been
a health elixir i'm telling you sprite
oh god dude that was a health drink
where i came from i'd be drinking that
on the side of the [ __ ] soccer field
yeah and in the south anytime you got a
headache it was get you a can of coke
that's it yeah the sugar will level you
out you need some sugar some caffeine is
what you need yeah and some of that bc
you ever do use bc
the powder the aspirin powder they have
down there in the south it's real hick
[ __ ] it's aspirin but already crushed up
yes in the fa do you know what you're
talking about civil war type [ __ ] [ __ ]
that dude dumping it in a bullet hole
get the [ __ ] out of here in the
factories in north carolina they would
have a thing called the dope cart where
it was like a snack cart that would come
around and they would give you cokes and
they would pour bc powder into the cokes
and now how would you know that from
your experience on the factory floor uh
my grandfather was in textiles ah
that's pretty good
all right what was he doing in textiles
owning the company i was gonna say you
don't say you when you're in something
you
you're the financier the founders of
florida for god's sakes
the original floridaman
uh yeah
i wouldn't say my you know i think
in-text styles is the way to go for the
owner of the business that's what i'm
saying yeah
if you're on the line you go i'm in
textiles no you're in whoever hired you
you're in debt yeah so are you check out
the patreon
let's talk about athletic greens ag-1
ag-1 baby
i'm not only a spokesman i'm also a
client the player president tell you i
started taking athletic greens why i
guess
i'm a real fat piece of [ __ ]
and i've been eating real bad yeah and
it's a one-stop shop takes care of you
immunity gut health the whole nine yards
like a mega multivitamin i bring it to
the gym with me i drink it throughout my
workout i'm telling you when i don't i
can feel 100 of a difference it's that
fantastic yes it has 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods superfoods not regular foods
foods
probiotics and adaptogens to help start
your day right does uh like you said it
takes care of your gut health your
nervous system your immune system your
energy recovery focus aging everything
you need ag-1 has you covered
uh best thing about it's lifestyle
friendly whether you're keto paleo uh
vegan dairy free or gluten-free they got
you covered or catholic
tons of people are taking some kind of
multivitamin it's important to choose
with high quality ingredients that will
do that your body will actually absorb
so ad1's got you covered
uh right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with a
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into cold and flu season just
one scoop and every just one scoop and a
cup of water every day that's it no need
for a bunch of different pills uh
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that's
athleticgreens.com garbage take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
today do it kip let's talk about bumpers
let's talk about bumbus gang bumba's
mission is simple make the most
comfortable clothes ever and match every
item sold with an equal item uh-huh
donate it yes how about that so when you
buy bumbas you're also giving to someone
a need gang yes they design their socks
shirts underwear to be the clothes you
can't wait to put on every day
everything is made soft seamless tagless
has a luxurious cozy feel i'm big on
luxury love that tagline that's a real
sign of clearance oh yeah not itching
back there scratching ripping it uh
t-shirts are made with uh thoughtful
design features like invisible seams
soft fabrics perfect weight so they hang
just right not all boxy or or dorky
looking socks underwear t-shirts are the
three most requested items in a homeless
shelter that's why bulma's donates one
for every item you buy go to bombus.com
garbage and get 20 off your first
purchase that's b o m b a s dot com
slash garbage for 20 off bumbas.com
garbage do it yeah anywho let's get to
some cues what do you think let's
do it gang as you know when you sign up
for the old patreon there you get the uh
you got a question ready read it oh boy
red on the air i apologize that one
pocket of my butthole
man
talk about talk about what's that
what's that therapy immersion therapy
where like if you're afraid of planes
they throw you out of one that's what
this episode is for me
i'm afraid of anything inside of you and
now i'm [ __ ] i'm looking down the
barrel of a gun
he's got a bunch of foley's
running around you you're just standing
there like that
batman reference
going to the well in the movie reference
is too much
i'm ill
anyhoo
tournament
all right this one uh uh this is from
kimmy clams
i don't know it's
almost got the big man
[Music]
a spit take into account yeah what's a
puke take what's that
not a lot
come on i didn't get it it was quick but
i didn't get it i get it now all right i
don't get it it doesn't take a lot for
you to puke okay it was quick it's a
quick math i'll buy that t-bone over
there
good job buddy
[Laughter]
such a
[ __ ]
you have to check out this week's
the pro whatever when what what is this
comes out like two day or a couple days
right yeah
the previous hard feelings is a doozy
and then the previous ayg
bonus
is chicken sandwich type level stuff
check it out bump the numbers
um
this is this is from kimmy one more time
and i'm only bringing this we've talked
about it but i'm only bringing it up
because it's something we do as a family
now
us three
go to gallagher's is it garbage to have
magnets all over your fridge of the
places you visited
we do that now
with the
totty fridge yeah we try and grab a
magnet from everywhere i think we have
almost we have most places maybe not
cities but we have all the states i got
florida in my bag
why
what do you mean why why is it in your
bag because i didn't bring it out of my
bag what do you think i'm holding it i
don't know it's my nft could you do that
make that an nft i don't die
i doubt it but i say no
i say no i say no
if that's all you have on your
refrigerator that's that's
no it's too kitschy it's trashy it's not
classy right let's let's reverse
engineer it if you're saying it's not
trashy what is it
it's classy
what
and by the way it's never like [ __ ]
you know
the maldives or something it's like
[ __ ] wild wood
you know what i mean it's not a lettuce
i don't know them all dies
you made that up no you're gonna endive
no i'm not uh you write my checks so i'm
with you kip
because what's the classy version of
that putin vibes over here yeah the
maldives the official republic of the
maldives
in the indian ocean
subcontinent of asia situated in the
indian ocean
because the classy version of that
southwest of sri lanka ooh i've been
there it would be like having like a
decorative horn and being like i got
this in the congo or whatever you know
not like i got this magnet at murder at
the airport yeah yeah no
it's trashy i there was one lady i knew
growing up that had it man it weirded me
out every i would just go and what
they covered their
uh
[ __ ]
uh refrigerator and magnets oh i think
it was like a family friend i remember
every time i went over i would just
[ __ ] side-eye it just made me nervous
it was too much too much going on it's
like lady what how do you [ __ ]
concentrate in this room [ __ ] 10 000
magnets on this [ __ ] fridge that was
empty
i
by
the
spending all the money on vacations yeah
how about running to the store and
grabbing an order uh grabbing an order
that's yeah i gotta go we'll do my mom
will say my mom will still say half an
order
got a half an order yeah
but why is that did they order it ahead
of time or something we're trash so what
we're talking about if you're not
generational garbage that's why i don't
know if it's a regional i feel like it
might be like a philly or regional thing
toby do you know this i would get i went
to the supermarket and got an order no
never heard that
yeah we'll still sell if we go down the
shore i just got down to shore i'm gonna
run the acme and get a half an order get
a half in order just like bread lunch
meat milk eggs whatever
but an order would be like whatever
you're getting yeah perked up on a
sunday when you heard that you knew some
fresh lunchy was coming french lush meat
some [ __ ] soft ass rolls and some
blue [ __ ] gatorade good let's go i've
heard the opposite of that in the uk
they say big shop
oh we're going down for the big shop
that's pretty funny
that's a big shop isn't it i went to a
big shopkin for a big shop some crispin
some fiddles um i because my mom will
say my mom will still be like that was a
280 dollar order yeah throw that in my
face
sure when i'll be like she'll like who
ate all this lunch me she would terry
terry
get down here
the fat one ate all the meat again i go
to the store they eat the whole box the
same night
terry i was i was him he's down there
trying to watch the game like what the
[ __ ] i was i was infamous where my mom
would go
drop like two tree bills at the super
fresh
and then i'd be like let's get dominoes
and she would be [ __ ]
i just spent 280 order
i didn't even unload the bag you didn't
even help me
ah you fat little bastard
i wanted the stump crust and breadsticks
from pizza hut man when that car pulled
up and then you got to go outside and
bring those bags that
was like trench warfare for me that was
the worst you were sending me brutal
death why i'm making [ __ ] three or
four i would leave whatever i could in
the garage oh we're leaving the milk out
here right
the soda's in a paper towel stay out
here what a piece of [ __ ] oh yeah those
plastic bags in the 80s and 90s would
slice your wrists up like the [ __ ]
chopper yeah brutal uh-huh i was yeah
real i think i've started my mom to keep
a lot of stuff in the garage just
because my laziness in the 90s
would your mom have to play defense
about your about your lunch supplies
like on a saturday and sunday
we weren't allowed to touch that stuff
no like i said single mom at that point
we had free reign i mean
whatever door my brother didn't [ __ ]
blow off the hinges by just being him
we she had [ __ ] she had bigger fish to
fry than the lunch it was a real tread
center yeah then the lunch meat
inventory in the meat drawer oh man if
we went near it because you know we had
the variety pack of chips you know i'm
talking to little bangers those didn't
stand a chance yeah we have those
[ __ ] there'd be yoohoos or high seas
lined up and man you got caught drinking
one of those on a [ __ ]
on a non-business day
[Music]
this is from foley's chin ever have your
picture taken by a slot machine that's
fake news right
[Laughter]
my chin doesn't know how to read or
write the third or fourth one what's
your what's the question uh ever taking
a picture by a slot machine
no assuming that you've been on some
sort of winning end do you know anybody
that's ever struck decent at a casino
i 100 to
your aunt right your aunt please my
uncle mike god rest his soul
gentleman hard worker vice president
[ __ ] man's of america
solid
of a major major commercial insurance
company uh
i don't think it was much of a gambler
they went away
somewhere it was somewhere in arizona i
think
they got off the plane they were going
somewhere
walked up a couple of quarters in the
slots
hit for like 15.
17 18 jihad
yeah
that's 90s cash that's all right it's
all right but uncle sam's got to wet his
beak going out michael sam
yeah
not bad though i don't know anybody
that's uh
i don't know anybody that's ever had
that
yeah just that and now i i've told you
we had that one lottery lottery winner
who won on my other aunt and uncle's
block he won he won the pennsylvania
lottery kind of a stretch for a couple
mil yeah a guy who lived on your aunt or
uncle's block
you're repping that that's hey i'm not
repping you just said i told you we also
had the guy who lived on my aunt and
uncle's block they're the only two
people close to the uh lottery that i
would know or winning things that i
would know yeah
what about you
yeah uh i had a buddy out of college he
i was still in college he graduates a
year to older than me he hit for like he
hit with the his company i did like a
pool and he won like 2.8 or 2.7 mil you
quit ready to quit no went back to work
the next day yeah it was like showed up
for dollar wings that week
bought a hat he just got married and
just had a kid oh that makes sense yeah
so he's like bought my house like bought
a house and [ __ ] you know
chilling that's clean living right there
never have to worry about money again
just go you got the bennies through the
[ __ ] company you had a good like
government s job type thing or whatever
yeah not too bad um all right this one's
from dylan haven't had one read yet this
one is bonko's know any old-timers that
put pepper in their draft beer to keep
ahead on it do you know my [ __ ]
godfather really oh yeah i've never even
heard of that have you seen people put
salt in their beer cause that's also
[ __ ] crazy but i've never even heard
of that pepper and beer i figured that
would take the head away
yeah it doesn't make sense that's the
nose grease
thing playing beer pong yeah big fan of
that i'll nose grease all day long sure
it's weird i would let my buddies nose
grease the beers do you let your buddy's
nose grease your beer like if we're
playing beer pong and my buddy knows
grease is it that's all i mean you're
this is this is wartime you know what i
mean there's a bigger there's a bigger
obstacle at hand there's a mission at
hand to win this beer pong game
that's your fury yeah
it is the best job i ever had
[Laughter]
it's weird the old-timers when they want
they want like a make sure there's a
good head on that they want a strong
head when you pour the beer uh-huh
there's no head on that
i remember as a server
getting some real old-schoolers you know
how you when somebody gets a bottle of
beer
hello is that a big shop your buddy won
the other night patty the baddie
yeah my buddy i thought he i thought you
were rooting for him sure all right
relax obviously there's a feud
man
he's gonna tune you up i don't know i
just basically talking [ __ ] she said my
buddy won the other night i didn't
expect you're [ __ ] johnny ufc i don't
know i figured you like him
i've never heard kimmy talk about the
ufc he does he watches it all the time
he goes to bars to wash it to watch it
oh man big man's big man's about to drop
and you like that kid you're gonna get a
standing tent county you keep slurring
your words you like that guy tyson tyler
whatever his name is tyson tyler chicken
big fan yes
um
he's a boxer i know
uh yeah okay i guess i'm john
on the show i guess i am johnny you are
and you're you're also now jerry formula
one too because you were talking now you
get into formula one i've watched some
programs uh-huh yeah
very european of you
keep an eye on you okay so you're naming
ted cruz i mean dude you're watching
guys you're watching reruns of columbo
probably for the seventh time
so is toby it's so [ __ ] good dude
they think he's done he's probably
watching
they think he's dumb he's actually smart
he gets him everyone watched it live
when it was on with your family it might
have still maybe been all when i was
younger you've seen a ep you've seen a
live televised episode of columbo yeah
one more thing i just share my pants
dude there's i was watching an episode
last night he's smoking a cigar in a
hospital
columbo plays by his own rules too yeah
he's gonna crack the case it doesn't
matter he's always hiding in their house
when they come home and he flicks the
ladder hey one more thing the [ __ ] you
doing where's your warrant
all those cases got thrown out i'm sure
yeah
unlawful search and seizure god damn it
colombo
hey i wrote it down in my no cuddy honey
they did a bit where he's just he walks
up to a crime scene he's a little sleepy
columbo you get a good night's sleep and
he's just cracking a hard-boiled egg
getting egg shells all over the
crime scene
and what the [ __ ] is dna
[Laughter]
columbo was all right
so do yourself a favor
and what were we saying what was the
question uncle likes salt on his
watermelon my uncle likes salt on his
watermelon no this was pepper on the top
of beer for to give it a give it head
you ever have the old school guys you
pour them
they buy a bottle of beer and it comes
with a glass and you go to nah nah nah
nah i'll pour it and they because they
know how they know how they like it
bored yeah we uh yeah
i grew up never uh
if you all i
i won't take a glass at a my dad was a
bottle guy and every time he ordered a
bottle michelob shout out only in ipa
would i needed a glass and then they
would give them a no glass so i just
thought that's what a man man to me you
were you know you were kind of a pansy
if you were walking around drinking your
beer out of a glass of candy i don't
know those high glasses they had in the
80s those were nuts i draft yeah but
then the bottle should be in the bottle
that was that was the school of thought
i'm talking about the thin thin ones
that the pilsner glass yeah yeah yeah
they're good for stealing
throw a couple of them in a bird's purse
on a way out see you later was columbo a
drinker or was he just tired
i he has a drink every now and again
out of the flask
no never a flask he had some
he gets offered some drinks he has him
every now and again yeah sure
i was singing one more thing it'd be fun
to do a fake fad diet where you do the
colombo diet and you only eat or drink
what what peter falk eats on the show so
you'd get like a ham sandwich two cigars
here's 19 cigars in a hard-boiled egg oh
man
this prostate must have been true to
roof
shout out to colombo shout out to
peacock playing the old hits
little phrase hey tv land check back in
will ya
nick at night what are we doing we're
broadcasting here not going over the
goddamn tv guide all right kip you know
all for him love all form you know all
forms i love all because we all love
helix who don't like right we love helix
masters one every night that's right you
do and thank god helix is getting out of
the bedroom give me a couple of minutes
to catch my breath and moving into the
sofa game with all forms oh yes
comfortable yes reliable uh-huh easy to
set up easy-peasy
i slept on one the other day when i was
at my sickest i know and it comforted me
you almost died on an all four i almost
added it all for him uh guys hit me up
for starters it's the easiest way you
can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional storage you pick your fabric
if you want spill stain resistant
scratch resistant the color the color of
the legs the sofa size the shape
whatever you need they can do it from a
love seat up to an eight-seat section
eight seats eight seats you got seven
friends you're hanging out with you're
pretty cool get yourself an old i don't
know seven people um they sent one to us
we got one right over there like the big
man said he almost died on it uh it's
fantastic i put it together all by
myself in about 25 minutes it's easy
peasy it's like a lego good stuff
fantastic
um they even offer a forever warranty
that's literally forever to find your
perfect sofa check out allform.com
garbage all form is offering twenty
percent off all orders for our listeners
at allform.com garbage one more time all
form.com just do it let's talk about
blue chew blue
talk about blue chew i want the full
attention of all lip dicks and whiskey
dicks out there
all the lds and wds stand at attention
stop trying to play it straight baby
yeah get a little help from the inside i
know get on the blue chew yes
uh got a long night in the south end of
something i need something to get the
motor going blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
a chewable tablet look at that fraction
of the cost take them any time day or
night so you can plan ahead or be
running whenever the opportunity
all rises process simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of the
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive the
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online no weird doctors
visits no walk for conversations no
waiting in line at the pharmacy so you
know just straight boating yes exactly
get
let's cut the cheese i know what are we
doing get to the business
tablets are made in the good old usf
look at that paired and shipped directly
to your door in a discreet package so
the neighbors ain't sniffing around it
doesn't come saying boner boner alert or
whatever
um
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time bluetooth uh
can help and we have a special deal for
our listeners try bluefruit bluetooth
free when you sign up when you use our
promo code garbage at checkout just pay
five dollars for shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code garbage to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details very
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast now back to that absolutely all
right this one's from andrew is it
garbage to go on vacation in the same
state you live in mind you i live in
maine not bora bora
i think but maine is beautiful going to
the lake or something like that
yeah that's okay i think a weekend
getaway is all right if you're going in
the same place for like a week if you're
taking off work and only going a couple
hours away i feel that's pretty tough
you think well i mean a couple hours
away that's the jersey shore i know i'm
go i'm operating within the question he
that's a different state i'm operating
within the the reality he's created here
you live in maine you have plenty of uh
you know beautiful waterfalls
wildlife wildlife you got lakes you have
rivers you have streams yeah ocean
where
in maine really yeah it's on the coast
where the steelers from joe list but
they have the most coastline of any
uh google that
and if not that's going back to joe list
but california clearly has the most i
think that's the big thing
maine's this big i think that's just
what everybody thinks i could be wrong
this is what he claims all the time
i'm checking it out now does maine
really have more shoreline than car than
california it does suck my what svetibol
how's that possible
he he's now you have to defend it like
you like you were the one who researched
so maine is longer than california more
coastline
that
california's coastline runs the entirety
of the state yeah but maine probably
[ __ ] clearly means bigger than you think
it is huh
well you know what it's trash now
because he lives in maine so he'd go
[ __ ] himself how about that wayne's all
right i've been to maine once clean the
blueberries are good up there right here
livin's easy it's what they say yeah
they have johnny cakes but i do that we
can get away it beats california by 51
miles how is that possible
i i i don't know man sky's blue
maybe there's islands
water's wet maybe there's islands that
they're counting no it's coastline blows
my mind california takes up
the country when traced in closer detail
the length of maine's scenic coastline
expands more than 15-fold the state's 3
478-mile tidal shoreline is the fourth
longest in the nation even beating out
expansive states like texas and
california there you go that makes my
brain hurt
now i feel like we're in a simulation
hello
someone get me a sandwich
for vacations i think the rule should be
a five hour drive or you have to cross a
state line
that's pretty good new york you could go
up to the finger lakes are beautiful
you know yeah they are
okay i mean how old are we this is a
family show there each fully if we found
out if you found out for sure that we
were in a simulation i don't like
thinking about that cause i'm never
gonna stop thinking about it would you
would you let me eat whatever i want
what do you mean
if we found out we were in a simulation
would you let me eat whatever we want
no because in this simulation
this is my reality was in the simulation
whether where that reality lies this is
my reality and my reality is if you die
the podcast is over and my gravy train
he's is parked in the lot okay hey
everybody welcome back to the joe bozo
experience yeah are we in a simulation
somebody give me some dnt and i'll
figure this out
somebody give me a couple of bud lights
let me get to the bottom of this thing
no glass some medium well elk meat
[Laughter]
i don't even know what i don't
understand that when people say we live
in a simulator i don't know i don't know
what the [ __ ] simulation where to me
there's something i don't know what that
means well like in an arcade that's what
i think we're in an arcade
what am i wreck it ralph what do we do
yeah that's what i don't know i
genuinely
this is why our show is about macaroni
and cheese and brushing your teeth in
the shower because we're stupid i can't
wrap my head around that i genuinely i
feel like i'm a pretty smart kevin's
head more coastline than maine
and california
combined yeah
google that yeah and your waistline
yeah i don't know i just can't wrap my
head around plenty of vacation spots
down there too
you go down the south of the border
plunking in that thing
man that was a pull that let's get
plunkett when you sneak in those little
holes and stuff
and the crevices isn't it i hate to do
it to you you're so close it's
spelunking
you're thinking cave diving you're
thinking of the children's game kerplunk
i am but what's kerplunky hey we're
going we're going we're going whatever
the joke hit that's all that matters
what's its kerplunken that doesn't sound
right
it sounds like something to get in the
red light district in belgium
uh
splunking hold on let me see
yeah it's when you're hiding when you're
crawling in those holes and stuff and
like caves and crevices and stuff before
you look at it you go nobody can get in
and out of there and then you like
[ __ ] hold your breath count to 10 and
then you know
just saw that on tick-tock that'll freak
you
i would never do that [ __ ]
oh thanks
hey guys everybody take that down don't
invite him to your splunking parties
okay to big man's out
hi i've seen you get caught in a
pull-out couch what are you talking
about can't fit in the car
uh
you [ __ ] idiot
um simulation
[Music]
this is from scott b we're in and out of
a lot of hotels
i would like to know
both of your etiquette
ever just leave change for housekeeping
when checking out of your hotel
no but i would i can admit
a lot of stiffen i feel on your part
while you do tip a lot
i feel like that might be overlooked
during the checkout procedures only
problem is what
when i'm with my lady no
right it's gotta come i gotta come
correct
but there's no witnesses when when we're
we're doing these [ __ ] in and outs
[ __ ] out of there at six a.m i don't
got [ __ ] cash on me
what can i do
you know
sure but when i do so you're stiffening
them is what you say so what do i do
when i ain't got no cash i stifle it's a
simulation
yeah tell that to a poor lady who can't
pay your bills
um i didn't know that was a thing until
this show that's insane tipping you
really what you have for the chambermaid
i had no idea
that's old school
it's not staying at long shanks
welcome to leo the lions um
ten dollars
i'll do up to ten depends on the cash
because i got all the cash from the
merch
the night before
oh yeah when it comes to those things
i assume
how do i rationalize this to me you
assume you want me to pay for it i think
that's where you're i think that's where
you're creating the rooms are on the
club
the club doesn't take care of that no
you're not tipping at checkout you're
not [ __ ] you're not signing the tip
goes to is is cash in the room i'm going
to make sure that i always have it on me
from here on out hit me up the night
before i'm just yeah and i'm technically
half your cash
i know you keep that tight on your hip
no everybody that goes all over the
place none of that comes home with me
that all gets [ __ ] spent greasing
this greasing that you got the dormant
you got the [ __ ] doorman we tip at
the club you got the [ __ ] the
waitress
she's handling us for bozos we grease
her pretty heavy yeah we never missed
that um
then just [ __ ] you know god damn it
stomach cramps two things i can't stand
stomach stomach aches and headaches
i'll take a broken bone
finger in the butt
sure
busted nail
okay
pink eye uh i i gotta be honest i never
really did that until recently tipping
tip in the room i just never again never
really thought about it you know
uh you just said you don't do it
currently
allegedly
no factually that's what you just said
and also i always thought i think i
didn't tip because i thought they worked
on an hourly rate if i'm like they're
getting like you know i don't know
12.50 an hour i just figured they were
stealing towels and selling them
rooting through my
bags um
the peak they get when i'm showering i
just figured that but then i looked it
up i think i think i had this
conversation with somebody they get paid
per room
they don't get paid hourly damn they get
paid per room it's all right it's like
contractual piecework or something
t-bone see if you get to the bottom the
[ __ ] is piecework what are you talking
about piece work like a non-profit yeah
you do 10 000 you do like you paid for
what you do i think it's well from now
on we're making sure
20 a clip
that's a lot i think is it one night i
mean we're literally in the room for 12
out not even all right we have the room
for ten dollars but i could tell you
this five dollars or something anything
involving change is a tip is bad it's a
jerk off move if it's a say you leave a
10 and some change that's fine you got
to you got to come in the door with the
10.
but it just changes the only place
change goes is in the cup
yes there you go
does that work
you should be doing a bill if you got
you know if you got money eat out
[ __ ]
hit him with it what do you got t-bone
uh
it seems like the the it's kind of all
over the place probably depends on state
area the whole thing yeah yeah yeah
hourly wages as high as 34 38 an hour
and as low as seven dollars that's gotta
be like the [ __ ] wall door for
something yeah yeah and that's not a tip
in me that's not where we're staying
and then as low as 7.93 cents an hour
which is nuts in 2022 that's great you
can't even buy lunch with that
the fact that you don't
i mean i know i i one thing i'll tell
you i do always do i clean up my clean
up for myself oh yeah i put all my
towels in the corner all my towels into
one corner everywhere i yeah spread my
seed
i mean looked in the room it was all
towels
you you leave it's like a hangover yeah
i know how messy you are
pizza boxes this is hearsay conjecture
uh no i just turned the room into a best
buy the second i walk in it's like
[ __ ] radio electronics everywhere
wires chargers [ __ ] booster packs
even pre-pandemic how do you feel about
them coming in and cleaning the room
while you're staying there
i just had it when i was in the
dominican republic um
i don't mind it i feel a little violated
i don't like you rooting through my
skivvies it's nice after a couple of
days you got to be ready for them it's
nice after a couple yeah let me get my
[ __ ] together i don't want you having a
you know but in the dominican republic
they would always put two l two
presidente [ __ ] beers in the mini
fridge for you so you come in you hop
out of the shower or whatever
look a couple cold woods they're plonk
one of them bad boys those are
presidentes ain't too shabby yeah
they're little guys too they were a
little like [ __ ] eight ounces or
whatever it's just
what the whistle yeah get you ready to
go uh-huh something for you brush your
teeth yeah
um all right this is for mope
uh
f-t-l-t
h-y-o-a-y-k first-time long time have
you or anyone in your anyone you've
known been to a lingerie football league
game
i gotta tell you those ladies were
getting after it the what the one league
where they where they wear bikinis and
like have like kind of shoulder pads
that's this they're all smoking and
they're [ __ ] hitting hard yeah dude i
forget who it was it was like one
one coach was like an ex linebacker in
college or something he's like you
[ __ ] go out there and [ __ ] hit her
and like dude they were just going out
and clobbering
[ __ ] time i would do something like
that
for the sport coach no go to it
oh yeah go to try out you got to support
the arts you know what i mean
either that or show and tell
uh yeah no that's funny
they still can't do it right
yeah why not
why can't they do it i'm saying i i
i'm not saying i'm saying it still can't
be a thing it's had that had to stop
existing
why you say that
have you seen ads for it or anybody
talking about it have you you've been
invited to a game i've
i've seen clips on instagram and stuff
yeah but i mean it could be some clips
of world war ii on instagram doesn't
mean it's [ __ ] happening still going
on i mean it might be i don't know but
i'm just saying you don't it's not
talked about that was big couple of
years ago
very maxum magazine yeah
t-bone you got anything
no there doesn't seem to be there seems
to be a little bit of a rebranding done
i'm listening do they need sponsorship
legends football league yeah
that sounds canadian though
the legends football league
should we sponsor a team
we should we sponsor something listen i
was going to bring this up to you
we should sponsor a little league team
no too small you're thinking you're too
too small-minded think bigger okay super
bowl halftime commercial
just me and you doing two and eight
minutes of the podcast buy into the nfl
something maybe you know i would do like
i did i did realistically
we could probably
you know if we sold our if we sold our
controlling interest in the podcast we
could probably get enough cash to get
like a minor league baseball team in
like
mexico or dominican republic or
something and you make your money
selling merch and [ __ ]
corn dogs
really
you're telling me we could be majority
owners of the juarez rockets
the new mexican rink rats i tell you
what that might not be a bad life down
there
buddy what do you think this is all
going towards
i
i'm waiting till i reach my number and
i'm cashing it in i'm buying a [ __ ]
rinky dink stadium down there and i'm
[ __ ] being jackie moon of [ __ ]
mexico city
you for a washing machine
um all right this is from chat tiddle
don't think that's his government name
do you ever avoid cleaning something for
taste my dad wouldn't clean the coffee
pot because he said that's where the
flavor was that's crazy that's bad
that's bad that and then we have also
gotten a lot uh
oh have you ever reused coffee grounds
oh i'm gonna get the big man going
do you like oysters
in a dirty ashtray
i think that's what might have got me i
had oysters on friday
and right now it's sunday to break the
fourth wall a little bit that sounds
about right right 24 hours
no that's not 24 hours 48 hours
something i mean you just keep moving
the goal post to fight the narrative 88
days what do you want from me 172 hours
something's running through me
um i don't know what it is burger king
oysters never steered me wrong before
uh
[Laughter]
to make oyster good one t-bone
you're losing weight you look great um
my that's patreon.com
i'm telling you you gotta check it out
it's a bit of a scene i'm not a fan um
now will that be an episode you watch
no no that one that one's getting buried
on how that one's going in with hoffa
that's going to be under the 50-yard
line at the meadowlands that's deathbed
confession [ __ ] yeah okay um
my family
there were certain glasses where you
couldn't put milk in them because they
drank beer out of them and that ruined
the beer
y'all ruined a beer yeah that was the
only thing don't put the milk in there
gonna ruin a beer even if you washed it
really yeah
not why i mean a skillet maybe like a
cast iron skillet yeah that the coffee
pot
that's crazy doesn't make my [ __ ]
blood run cold a little bit that's where
the you're supposed to clean it with
like vinegar and [ __ ] like that yeah
um
also we get a lot of times too we get uh
we go i mean we probably get this one
weekly from patreon so i don't you know
um have you ever reused coffee grounds
that's that's
what i've done it in a pinch day same
day like i would have like a french
press i would do the french press and i
wanted like another cup of coffee
oh if you're pouring it just ran it
through again and was like whole pot or
just a little bit like a half guy yeah
yeah yeah
just to wet the whistle i got you you
know what i mean wasn't my proudest
moment but it was also like [ __ ]
colder than a witch's tit in january i'm
not walking to [ __ ] dunkies or the
starbeezies to get a coffee yeah
that i can understand but not cleaning
it that's that's nuts yeah that's
[ __ ]
that's too much
we've had a couple of
[ __ ] tough-looking grills too
floating around the shore or you open it
up and you're like all right looks like
we're doing takeout i'm not [ __ ]
dealing with that
yeah
pizza burger salmon grill and
everybody's booze in you know and then
it gets dark and you're like oh well
it's been sitting out there for two
hours just closed that's not the first
thing we did we turned a girl and we
blast that [ __ ] for like 10 minutes of
course and then go out there
you got to to use that but i'm saying
sometimes you got cancer loose you do a
[ __ ] pump fake you take a peek and go
no thank you
um
[ __ ] oh yeah i know what i was gonna say
did you or any member of your family or
any friends families
reuse like bacon grease and stuff like
that like where it was in a coffee can
and then they would ladle it out into
the thing to cook stuff but for like
lard-esque type stuff yeah no
that would make your house smell like
[ __ ]
trust me yeah my my family never did it
but i had one
friend whose mom did it and it always
smelled
like a kennedy fried chicken in there it
was just a tough look yeah it's just
like triple fried grease and stuff you'd
almost want a gag yeah what my mom does
is she'll do
she'll put it in a coffee can
straight down to sick for me she will
um
at times
but she you for the the law the
procedure for a long time was coffee can
in the freezer so it would harden
and then she would throw that out oh
that's pretty good yeah or like she
would just go dump it in like the
[ __ ] backyard or whatever but most of
the times
just hot water at a garbage disposal
will go yeah
yeah
[ __ ] the grandkids i mean
that's their problem yeah you guys
forgot the plumbing in 20 years
it was [ __ ] out
especially with a garbage disposal
everything went down there
dog [ __ ] the dog whatever yeah didn't
matter mm-hmm
[ __ ] out of here i got this this is the
thing i was thinking about i was late
today because i was walking hans
and uh he wasn't pooping hence why i was
late i had this [ __ ] little [ __ ] out
you all jammed up little metamucil maybe
nah just you know
is he getting enough fiber yeah he's
doing all right
um
does he like a cigarette after a dump
what's his deal he doesn't but he
watches me while i have one while he
dumps for sure i'm there catching
heaters out front you ever catch a win
my smoke my bernie number is true to
roof i gotta tell you you ever catch
wind of that when you're when you're
standing over top of them no it's all
right but it's tough because you got to
be johnny on the spot with the treat to
make the connection that pooping outside
gets me the treat you can't there can't
be that much lag time so you gotta
[ __ ] imagine imagine taking a deuce
and someone shoving a brownie in your
face
it's a stressful situation for the
little guy
you quick with the with the grab uh i
mean not quick but you know
here's a question have i left it be
honest stop okay
have you left it i haven't my wife has
she forgot she's a guy i got she did she
told me she's like i forgot i got so
distracted i got bags
no she just forgot to get it
okay uh if you call my [ __ ]
[ __ ] foreign investor a liar
um
but we have what we call poop alley
there's this like street that no one
lives on
there's this street no one lives on like
i said where they just broken all those
cars because there's nothing on it
that's poop alley they broke into all
the
cars dog [ __ ] no one's got eyes on you
if you're leaving it
you know what i mean right lights big
city poop alley
cause someone breaks into your car i
mean if you're
you got to feel pretty bad about
yourself when you walk back there the
next day and your his dump's still there
talking to me yeah
no i didn't leave it she said she forgot
you forgot and also it's like of course
whatever i mean you know no i always
pick it up the one time i yesterday he
did take a a diesel
and i was out of bags
so i did the appropriate thing put it in
your pocket
jimmy's out there raw dog in it
the [ __ ] like a gentleman i took it home
and put it in the toilet and flushed it
um
[Laughter]
they say that's what you're supposed to
do no you're supposed to bury it so you
can grow a poop tree
on blue valley
no his problem is he i haven't so we
went over and i had my i had my wife go
to the deli i needed a water so she
bought a water got the plastic bag
did it that way because those deli still
give you the plastic bags you can't use
the [ __ ]
those like see through those tree hugger
jumps yeah nah man they'll have a
handful of [ __ ] wet wet turds
um
target bag ain't gonna help you now boy
good old-fashioned plastic
but
what was i saying
i forget i got lost oh dog taking a [ __ ]
oh but then he won't goat he won't walk
to the because he's going yo i'm done
let's [ __ ] let's hightail it out back
to the house yeah that's usually right
out front
but like a half a block down is the
trash can
like i you genuinely can't get him to
the trash can he just [ __ ] you don't
pick him up i will if it's like real
hemmed up
but
i just i can't bring poop into my
apartment that's a yeah right that's
insane are you crazy my wife was like
well just throw it out i'm like we're
not throw it out we're not bringing poop
in the [ __ ] kitchen i'm making a
[ __ ] bolognese and i got a [ __ ]
cleveland steamer next to me from a duff
from a [ __ ] shepherd i said no we're
not doing that yeah that's no good yeah
you never bring it back into the house
no no no no no no never
man yeah
i would just give it a
give it the old college toss dude it was
six o'clock this morning
and i'm doing the streets are empty and
it's a dude it's about 35 shot points
it's about 35 feet from me and i did i
was literally lining it up
ryan's in the on the 18th green my
neighbor walked out i was like hey kevin
and hans i'm like i hate doing it it's
about to be an airborne turd
but i didn't do it now i picked him up
and walked and brought him but then he
starts [ __ ] he's getting to be pretty
big now he starts [ __ ]
if you pick him up he's got to get him
in here before he gets too big
please that's the same thing about you
you still show up
you said you were going to bring him in
bring him in so we could see him i know
but i can't just bring him in what will
he do
he'll [ __ ] eat everything oh really
yeah
he's mouthing
excuse me that's what they call it
mouthing wait what you guys do in your
apartment your business
how do you know about that um all right
let's see here let's do one or two more
i'm gonna wrap it up
fun times here
uh i apologize for my illness
[Laughter]
the mental is what you're paying for
let's be honest yeah emotional is what
you get from paul uh your uber driver
picks you up in a pickup truck garbage
get the [ __ ] i'm not getting the next i
had it and it was an uber pool and i had
a city no it was in atlantic city and we
were going i was got you're riding [ __ ]
i didn't what do you know i didn't ride
[ __ ]
i think the guy was in the bat i think
it might have been a duel like a quad
cab what the [ __ ] are we doing i think
there was three of us i think there was
two in the back and i was in the front
or vice versa
yeah it's atlantic city ubers dude it's
lawless and it was uber pools and we had
to get we were both going to wildwood so
we [ __ ] split in ubs
yikes yeah
no i would i would dip well in the
suburbs
in new york there's the rules it has to
be
a car from the last six years they're
typically toyota camrys honda crvs
[ __ ] minivans one accord honda accord
but
in [ __ ] you know rural pennsylvania
it's just steve's [ __ ] car you know
what i mean it's lawless wide open i
would lose it
yeah
um
let's see hit me here
talk to me this is from dan what do you
got how do you cut the film on a tv
dinner do you slice it once with a knife
or stab it a bunch of times with a fork
like a gentleman i feel like we just
talked about this i think we might have
yeah i asked you guys your procedure for
plastic on top of microwavable things i
go both i can go either way depending on
the depending on the instrument
depending on the well what i'm looking
at mm-hmm some of them pull back and
seal
something very nice i just want you to
open it
i i like stabbing it though it's way
funner it is you're getting someone out
yeah you get something like the tomato
sauce
75s i don't think any of that [ __ ]
matters
no it just needs some sort of venting i
believe yeah yeah no i did a lot of r d
on the fork poke holes versus the slit
it's all the same [ __ ] yeah
now do you ever put those in the oven
those dinner treasures plastic can i
think you can no i'm pretty sure you can
put those tv dinners in the oven oh
that's crazy we're going to then we're
going to the well that's how you wind up
with a kid with a giant bald head
yeah [ __ ]
i got served a tv dinner once and it was
the last this guy this guy eating 3m for
dinner huh
old dupont danny over there
this guy have you guys ever had a
banquet microwave dinner goddamn right
we have
yeah pretty much all frozen meals can be
cooked in the oven wow this includes
breakfast burritos waffles entree meals
pasta burgers or popeyes
there you go love a pop i think that's
the preferred met that's the best method
so it's not all [ __ ] good well as a
kid we didn't microwave our tv dinners
they went they did go in the oven but
there wasn't what am i a jerk you didn't
keep the plastic on there
of course not oh
[ __ ] bozo yeah
i stand corrected thank you
gang we will return
in a week's time
no it'll be like
episodes come out every two or three
days what are you talking about we'll
return first time on the program in two
or three days all right later love you
peace